The Last Jedi is the second film in the
sequel trilogy but the first in that
trilogy to really deal with Luke
Skywalker in a major way director Ryan
Johnson had to not just introduce this
new version of Luke but also explain the
complex emotions that led him to abandon
his friends and the force it's one of
the most important parts of the movie
but some things still had to be cut one
of the most powerful Last Jedi deleted
scenes come shortly after Luke figures
out Han is dead we don't get to see Rey
and Chewie tell him that his
brother-in-law and friend is dead but
one deleted scene shows us the aftermath
signlin and shaken Luke sits down in his
Hut and tries to deal with the loss of
Han you can see the despair on his face
along with the guilt It's a Wonderful
performance for Mark Hamill but it wound
up on The Cutting Room floor